[Musique]
à l'heure où tous les peuples européens
dis STOP à l'immigration massive la
France se pose comme le pays qui
encourage la clandestinité épouse de
pauvres gens à risquer leur vie les
centres de rétention explosent vous
expulsez personne nos policiers
travaillent dans le vide d'une justice
qui ne suit plus les préfectures
débordent tandis qu' ancien ministre et
préfet des fils dans les médias pour
décrire l'inimaginable votre politique
s'est accueillir et répartir le
rassemblement national lui veut secourir
et reconduire ma question madame borne
l'océan Viking est actuellement à
Marseille allez-vous enfin faire votre
travail et mettre sous scellé ce navire
ou allez vous continuer de subir je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
finalement une question est simple si
vous étiez responsabilité
auriez-vous laissé mourir c'est 44
enfants
puisque vous donnez des leçons à la
terre entière et dites aujourd'hui
l'inverse ce que vous affirmez hier
permettez moi de faire le point sur
votre travail chaos Stade de France
mensonges d'État sur les supporters
anglais explosion des atteintes aux
personnes perchshif sécurité depuis des
décennies
humiliation par un imam étranger abandon
de Mayotte crise migratoire dans la
Manche et accostage de bateau de
migrants dans le sud dans une démocratie
normale on aurait des la vérité c'est
que nous avons secouru des femmes et les
enfants que malheureusement l'Italie n'a
pas voulu secourir la vérité madame la
députée c'est que nous avons fait preuve
d'humanisme quand vous faites de la
politique politicienne la vérité madame
la députée
c'est que vous n'êtes pas apte au
pouvoir parce que vous n'êtes pas
d'apprendre des décisions difficiles en
regardant les Français dans les yeux et
je m'endorgueille madame la députée que
soit cette majorité qui soit pouvoir
pour sauver ses enfants là avec vous on
sait ce qui serait devenu
[Musique]
sur ces 234 personnes au moment où je
vous parle l'ensemble des démarches ne
sont pas terminées 44 ont été reconnus
mineurs 60 peuvent demander l'asile
notamment des Syriens des Soudanais des
érythréens 44 se voit désormais un refus
opposé à leur demande d'asile dans la
zone d'attente qui est aujourd'hui celle
de la presqu'île de Gien comme vous le
savez pour les personnes qui peuvent
demander l'asile ceux qui ne présume pas
du fond évidemment de leur demande nous
allons permettre le répartition de ces
personnes sur le territoire européen 11
pays que je souhaite remercier ce qui
provient que la solution est européenne
[Applaudissements]